coup de pluie demain et par là
ce sera plus clément.
Pour terminer, je vous
le rappelle, on a appris ce soir
le décès de l'écrivaine
Marie-Claire Blais à l'rerereree
un riche héritage de plus
d'une cinquantaine de ....
Pour en parler ce soir,
notre collègue, l'animateur
Michel Desautels.
- Bonsoir Céline.
- Vous étiez l'un de ces
laquelle accordait des
entrevues. Quel souvenir vou
- D'abord beaucoup de chaleu
ce soir beaucoup de tristesse
des électeurs les plus fidèles.
Ils y en a qui l'ont suivi
depuis des décennies,
chance vous le disiez, de la
rencontrer en interview à
quelques reprises.
C'est très diffarararararce que
quand on a eu la chance de
percer le mystère Marie-Claire,
entrevue et en personne, vous
savez, les pho
ancienenenenenenenenenenenenenee
regard magnifique était toujours
caché par cette frange derrière
t t t t t t t t t t t t t t t te
manifestation physique de sonors
départs.
Et une fois qu'on avait réussie
à briser, afin de relever cette
mèche de cheveux, on découvrait
une femme qui était extrêmement
chaleureuse, qui aimait le
monde, qui aimait rire aussi. Ça
c'est très drôle. Et surtout qui
aimait l'humanité. Et ça, je n
saurais trop inviter les gens
qui ont été peut-être un peu
réticents à aller vers cette
littérature qui n'es, , , , , ,n
l'a reconnu partttttttt
pas toujours une oeuvre facile.
Et surtout le dernier cycle qui
s'est terminé avec une rencontre
près de la mère 12 ou 13 ans
plus tard. Ce sont 10 romans.
Mais ce sont des fleuves de mots
dans lesquels ont laissé, je le
répète, il n'y a pas de points.
Le reste, ce sont des virgules.
Elle nous oblige à nousimimimimt
surtout rentrer dans cette
humanité. C'est une femme qui a
toujours milité pour la défense
des minorités en tout genre,
qu'elle soit sexuelle, raciale,
économique.
- Militant pour la francophonie
aussi.
- Oui bien sûr. C'est
Et à l'étranger comme en France,
aux États-Unis, on reconnaît que
c'est une grandes écrivaines
francophones. Elle a été
traduite aussi en plusieurs
langues. Mais c'est surtout une
grande militante finalement.
Alors ce sont des romans, de
vrais romans, mais qui montre à
quririririririririque est
malade. À quel point l'Amérique
n'aime pas ses enfants, à quel
ururururururururures d'être unen
transsexuel, un tranchant,
d'être noir, d'être métis dans
ce pays. Et du début jusqu'à la
fin de cette oeuvre immens
a malgré tout un peu de lumière
qui sort, parce qu'il y a
toujours de l'espoir. Elle croit
cacher les gens dans le fond,
chacun d'eux, il y a assez de
force de l'de ces co
plus misérables. C'est une
romancière absolument immense,
pas facile, mais tellement... iy
a un beau cadeau, si on a la
patience de ce lancer dans sa
lectur d d d d d d d d d de la
lumière au bout du tunnel.
- La dernière fois que vous
l'avez eu à votre micro, c'était
je crois en 2018. Comment elle
percevait la suite de sa
carrière à ce moment-là? La
suite des choses pour elle?
t t t t t t t t t t d'écrire. Ee
était contente d'avoir fini le
seigle. Elle m'avait dit qu'ell.
Elle avait commencé à reprendre
certains de personnages en les
isolant davantage.
Une tribu dans une île
imaginaire. Elle avait reprisses
les autres. C'était une ambition
suivante, je ne sais pas où
aller n'en était, j'ignore les
circonstances dans lesquelles
elle est décédée, mais on a dans
Soif ce qu'il faut pour
découvrir l'Amérique
voyait.
- Elle a essuyé cert
critiques, certains l'accusent
de redondance dans ce livre.
Vous l'avez toujours soutenu.
- Soutenu... c'est-à-dire que ji
eu la patience d'aller ds ce
livre. Et elle reconnaît, elle
eaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaucoup de
gens-là l'abandonneraient en
cours de route, certains
p p p p p p p p p p p pas ouvra
première page devant ce flot de
mots. Moi j'ai eu cette patience
et cette humilité devant quelque
chose que je ne comprenais pas
toujours au départ. Mais au unes
quelques clés, si vous voulez
découvrir une certaine Amérique
d'aujourd'hui, c'est unermrmrmre
chez une femme qui était au
moins assez américaine
québécoise. Elle écrivait depuis
tellement longtemps. C'est une
façon de le faire. J'avais eu la
patience et parfois le courage
de passer au travers. C'est pas
toujours simple mais quel joie.
- Oui, elle a eu de nombreux
produits. Le magazine...
la place de la première place...
le fait qu'elle ne mettait pas
:, c'est une de ces raisons.
- Elle était extrêmement
appréciée aux États-Unis, à la
limite plus qu'ici. Dans le
circuit universitaire, elle
était accueillie partout en
star, mais pas maintenant depuis
des décennies.
tout ce qui compte en
littérature. Donc on doit être
trè
milieux ce soir d'apprendre que
Marie-Claire, la secrète Marie-
Claire toujours cachée dans sons
tout proches et qui ne détestai